this is graphene
it's a sheet of carbon atoms arranged in
hexagons but it's only one atom thick
you can see a very large sheet but very
thin very flexible and two physicists
and three gaim and Konstantin Novoselov
in University of Manchester here in
England have been honored for
discovering it and now I'm going to try
and do their experiment here in front of
you never tried it before let's see if
it works it begins with a piece of
graphite this is a piece of carbon which
is made up of lots of layers like this
stacked one on top of each other
thousands of millions in this tiny
sample and what Guymon nervous you love
suddenly realised is that they could
peel off layers from the top of this
that were just one atom thick so what
they did was they took a piece of sticky
tape and then if it was this brand but
stuff like this and they put it on the
top and pressed it down and just pulled
it off and they're sticking on it with a
sheet I think in this case I've rather
overdone it and taken off several sheets
and then what they did is they found
another surface and pushed the thing
down and peeled off the sellotape and
it's stuck mine hasn't stuck so I
wouldn't get the Nobel Prize for that
but what really excited physicists and
chemists was that for the first time you
could have a single sheet where which
was only one atom thick and so there are
bonds that on the atoms which can
interact with other things normally when
they're stacked together all these bonds
are interacting between one layer
another here you have a single layer of
carbon and this has opened up a huge
range of experiments for example
one of my colleagues here at Nottingham
and three flabby stuff has shown that if
you shine electrons on the sheet of
graphene you can get it to wrap up and
form a ball of c60 and he told me this
morning when I told him about the Nobel
Prize he's just shown you can't do the
other thing you can unwrap a bowl of c60
and make graphene so the two of them are
interchangeable and I think it's a great
prize it's very nice when somebody is
rewarded because they do an experiment
that everybody can understand I think in
this case it is right that it was the
Nobel Prize for Physics because the real
interest in this material is the way
that the electrons behave in these
layers graphite the carbon from which
the graphene is made is an electrical
conductor conducts electricity and when
you have a layer one atom thick the
properties are much more amenable to
quantum calculations to studying the
physical properties and it is probably
the physical properties of graphene that
are really exciting to scientists so I
think it's right that they should have
got the Nobel Prize for Physics it's
interesting that Rutherford could also
been a scientist at Manchester got the
Nobel Prize for chemistry and he didn't
really respect chemists